zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
die angst vor einer neuen corona bälle
in europa wächst die whu warnt die zahl
der neuen fälle ist allein in der
letzten woche um zehn prozent gestiegen
vermiest und stellt diesen sommer das
wollen wir heute hier besprechen mit
dabei sind karl lauterbach und der
virologe klaus stöhr und bevor wir in
das gespräch einsteigen schauen wir auf
einen gar nicht so pessimistischen
gesundheitsministeriums sparen wir haben
deutlich mehr möglichkeiten als vor
einem jahr
wir haben vor beginn der reisezeit klare
regeln
das war letztes jahr die wir uns
erinnern anders wir haben ein breites
testangebot und breite testmöglichkeiten
wir haben sehr viel informieren können
und werden auch weiter informieren und
wir haben bessere möglichkeiten zur
kontrolle etwa durch die digitale
einreise anmeldung und werden übrigens
noch etwas
wir haben die impfung die natürlich den
ganz entscheidenden unterschied machen
tja apropos impfungen weil delta sich
ausbreitet unter anderem deshalb hat die
ständige impfkommission heute ihre
empfehlungen für impfungen mit
astrazeneca geändert wer die erste
impfung damit bekommen hat sollte als
zweites nicht mehr astrazeneca sondern
moderner oder bei und heck bekommen also
ein mrsa impfstoff über die hintergründe
spreche ich mit professor christian
bogdan er ist mitglied der stiko und
kann uns erklären wie es zu dieser
entscheidung gekommen ist also zunächst
ist es sein dass die aufgaben der stiko
darin besteht permanent die datenlage zu
evaluieren endlich auch die wirksamkeit
der einzelnen impfstoffe und es ist in
der tat so dass mehrere arbeiten
erschienen insgesamt hier und wer
künftig ist unterwegs die ganze zeit
dass im endeffekt ja die kombination aus
dem master zenica
dort mit einem erwin stoff zu einer
stärkeren und antwort führt da wir die
aufgabe haben den bestmöglichen schutz
der bevölkerung anzubieten ist es
natürlich klar dass wir in der hinsicht
lässt die empfehlung ändern
diese ganze ist ein beschlussentwurf
gerne auf die tür aufmachen bevor sie
den rest der sendung weiter klingeln das
ist überhaupt kein problem herr
professor bogdan wir kennen das
inzwischen ausschalten aus dem
homeoffice nach diesem langen monaten da
können wir uns an diese situation
gewöhnt viele zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer fragen sich natürlich was
bedeutet das denn jetzt ganz konkret für
mich also wie groß sollte denn der
abstand zwischen der ersten und der
zweiten impfung seien ja ein bisschen
zwei verschiedene thema da die eben
abstände das muss man auch noch betonen
die wurden ja von der stiko unter
deswegen ideal etwas verlängert bei den
mrd nach impfungen weil der impfstoff
man existiert hat aber die zulassung der
ms stoffe beinhaltet ja nimmt abstand
von drei bis vier wochen
in der jetzt vorliegenden
pressemitteilung haben wir jetzt
mitgeteilt dass wir im hinblick auf eine
geste stelle erreichen einer
vollständigen immunisierung auf die
kürzesten info-stände zurücknehmen das
heißt also 21 tage ist also 28 tage bei
der reinen im arena info wenn man jetzt
geniesst im prolog mit astrazeneca und
eine marina impfstoff dann ist der
mindestabstand vier wochen an der stelle
auch noch eine aufforderung in die
community wenn ihr und sie fragen habt
gerade zum thema astrazeneca und zur
neuen empfehlung der stiko dann schreibt
uns das in die kommentarspalten in den
sozialen medien oder per e mail an diese
e mail adresse wenn ihr die zdf heute
nutzt ich schaue gerade mal rein
fernando dankt dem zdf für unsere arbeit
vielen dank zurück an dieser stelle
fernando und
die frage taucht natürlich auch auf
viele sind natürlich verunsichert die
schon zweimal mit astrazeneca geimpft
sind sind die jetzt weniger geschützt
als die anderen und das betrifft
natürlich auch viele junge frauen
erzieherinnen lehrerinnen die gerade in
den ersten frühjahrs monaten zweifach
astrazeneca geimpft worden
nein also machen sie jetzt will ich ganz
klar sagen die momentan vorliegenden
daten zeigen dass die grundsätzliche
immunantwort noch etwas besser sein kann
das bedeutet in keiner weise das jetzt
jemand der zwei mal mit astrazeneca
geimpft wurde nicht gut geschützt ist
das ist ja mittlerweile hervorragend
belegt dass eine zweifache impfung
wirklich sehr sehr gut
um schwere erkrankungen von
hospitalisierungen schützt und
dementsprechend müssen die menschen
jetzt zweimal mit astrazeneca gfk sind
wirklich nichts befürchten
es geht einzig allein um die frage wenn
wir jetzt in die zukunft schaut
möglicherweise auch auftreten von von
eben varianten die nicht mehr ganz so
gut durch die momentan im stufe
erfassbar sind was kann man dann noch
gegebenenfalls verbessern alles in
rheine immunogenität daten bisher und
insofern bitte keine keine beunruhigung
und und vor allem nicht dann wenn man
bereits zweimal geimpft ist sind jetzt
gerade sehr ermutigende daten auch
rausgekommen für astrazeneca dass also
der impfschutz wirklich sehr lange
anhält wahrscheinlich mindestens ein
jahr das jetzt die beobachtungs dauer
die man maximal haben kann und
dementsprechend also in der hinsicht ein
grund zur beunruhigung für diejenigen
die zweimal us patienten können sie
trotzdem die verunsicherung der menschen
verstehen denn es gab ja auch viele
situationen den impfzentren wo leute
astrazeneca ist geimpft waren und dann
die entscheidung welche zweitimpfung sie
wollen zum beispiel selbst treffen
mussten weil ärzte gesagt haben wir
können ihnen das auch nicht beantworten
es gibt diese empfehlung es gibt andere
empfehlungen es gibt zu wenig daten
wir wissen es auch nicht so genau diese
menschen mussten diese entscheidung
selber treffen
jetzt gibt es diese empfehlung die
wiederum die menschen verunsichert
können sie das verstehen
nochmal recht drücken
es gab eigentlich von anfang an immer
eine sehr klare aussage was die aktuell
gültige empfehlung ist nur der ist es zu
wachsen ist schon wirklich sehr schnell
und deswegen musste auch die stiko ein
paar mal die dinge verändern also zum
beispiel den umstand dass menschen unter
60 jahren eben überhaupt sehr viel mehr
nur noch mit ml dahin vom kreativ werden
sollen und die ihnen die damals ein
erster zenica in form bereits bekommen
hatten
den hatten wir dann empfohlen eine e
mail von subjekten dazu bekommen und das
ist aber auch ganz klar kommuniziert
worden und da gab es jetzt auch keine
kann die verwirrung in der leaf zentren
das einzige was jetzt eben neu
hinzukommen ist die situation dass diese
technologie in form also astrazeneca als
erstes im arena als zweites eben jetzt
nicht mehr alleine für diejenigen gilt
die unter 60 jahre alt sind eben eine
erstmalig als patientin von bereits
bekommen hatten und denke wir müssen
akzeptieren dass wir in einer situation
wo auch die forschung hier laufend neue
ergebnisse liefert und das ist unsere
aufgabe entsprechend der daten dass dann
auch anzugleichen
sehen sie die gefahr dass jetzt zu wenig
impfstoff da sein wird weil auch alle
astrazeneca erst geimpften eben jetzt
die im rna impfstoffe brauchen werden
also ich werde jetzt nicht diejenigen
die jetzt genau voraussagen können ob
die firmen ihre ihre lieferzusagen
einhalt ist auch nicht nur uns der
aufgabe als stiko wenn man jetzt
allerdings die zahlen zugrunde legt die
auch die politik und verliert hat im
hinblick auf das was jetzt geliefert
werden wird und was in angekündigt wurde
sehe ich da wirklich ein problem
also wir werden nach den zusagen die
moment jetzt vorliegen nicht in eine
einen impfstoffmangel hineinlaufen nur
deswegen weil jetzt gegebenenfalls eben
wie sie ältere logo in form stattfindet
ich würde gerne eine letzte frage noch
aufgreifen und zwar ganz konkret zu
einem impfstoff von grey shadow über
youtube der user oder die userin
schreibt wie sieht das ganze für den
impfstoff von johnson & johnson aus ist
man dort auch ohne zweiten emmerich
impfstoff gut gegen delta geschützt dazu
kann man meines erachtens im moment noch
gar nichts sagen also ich kenne jetzt
jedenfalls aktuell keine arbeit die das
bedeutet hätte ben johnson & johnson
impfstoff muss man ja auch noch mal
wirklich betonen dass die einmalige
impfung ja nur deswegen überhaupt als
als zulassung und empfehlung existiert
weil die firma in der zulassungsstudie
studie eben nur diese eine impfung
durchgeführt hat aber es gibt eine eine
studie auch in amerika mindestens eine
die eine einmalige zweimalige impfung
vergleicht und 3 0 mono logistik ist für
extrem wahrscheinlich dass bei johnson &
johnson dem stoff genauso wie auch beim
us patent für die mittel- und
langfristige schutzwirkung der
zweimalige impfung notwendig sein wird
in welcher form das dann stadt wien wird
ob dann mit zweite johnson johnson kommt
oder eben auch eine impfung das werden
die zukünftigen arbeiten zeigen
ich würde gern tatsächlich weil hier
noch zwei interessante fragen
aufgetaucht sind die noch mit rein
nehmen die eine ist doris stielow fragt
über facebook wenn ich jetzt die zweite
impfung erst in drei wochen habe somit
drei monate mit astra ist der abstand zu
groß um die zweite m rna impfung zu
erhalten also das beschreibt natürlich
das problem dass viele astra erst
geimpfte sehr späten zweiten impftermin
hatten weil der zeitraum ja sehr viel
länger war bei den bei den impfstoffen
jetzt braucht man aber schneller an
impftermin was macht man da jetzt
überhaupt kein problem sie brauchen gar
nicht
hier brauchen bis es seinen mini den
minimalabstand es ist eine wichtige
botschaft ja immer logisch ist ja
überhaupt kein problem einen infostand
zu verlängern
ja das ist nur dann ein problem wenn
nach der ersten impfung und dann keinen
schutz mehr da ist aber beim astra
zeneca impfstoffen wissen wir ja dass
nach einer erstmalig erstmalig der
impfung für zwölf wochen im schutz
besteht das heißt man muss es an der an
der ursprünglichen an den ursprüngen im
vorstand der mal geplant war für die
zweitimpfung gar nichts ändern
wobei wenn ich da durchaus einen haken
darf die zahlen lägen ja nahe dass es
gerade bei der delta variante und astra
nach der
ersten impfungen in sehr geringen schutz
gibt ja ja das ist jetzt die zweite
komponente die wir jetzt eben bedenken
muss dass eine ist immer die frage wie
beschützt habe ich gegenüber den bisher
zirkulierenden virusvarianten und die
zweite frage ist natürlich immer wie
verhält sich das wenn jetzt eine neue
virusvariante auftritts ja und da kann
es natürlich jetzt tatsächlich so nicht
darstellen und das ist auch einer der
gründe warum wir jetzt diese technologie
impfung empfehlen und natürlich dann
auch in einem möglichst kurzen abstand
damit eben schnell die zweite impfung
aufgegeben ist dass es hier eine gewisse
unterlegenheit da sein kann
aber bitte man muss immer nämlich
bedenken jeder mensch jedes individuum
zeigte auch eine individuelle antwort
und dann kann jetzt nicht alle über
einen kamm scheren und einfach sage ist
und ich muss jetzt auch biegen und
brechen jetzt jeden punkt genau in der
erfahrung mit der zweite punkt versehen
also da muss man einfach mal ein
bisschen realistisch bleiben und warum
es auch natürlich es so durchgehend wie
sie jetzt von der planung her auch
möglich ist ok dann letzte frage von
sancho banana über youtube ich werde
sonntag zum zweiten mal geimpft kriege
ich jetzt wie beim ersten mal astra oder
moderner bayern tag oder darf ich es mir
aussuchen
naja da kommen wir jetzt in das kleine
problem hinein dass das was heute als
pressemitteilung mitgeteilt wurde ja
noch nicht der offizielle stiko
beschluss ist also wir haben im
endeffekt ein ganz normales verfahren
dass heißt der stiko beschlussentwurf
wird in einstellungen damit verfahren
gegeben und danach noch mal zurück gibt
gespiegelt an die stiko und dann gibt es
die endgültige beschlussfassung in der
annahme dass ich da jetzt vielleicht
nichts ändern wird
dann gibt diese stiko empfehlung ab dem
zeitpunkt der veröffentlichung
das heißt also erst einmal herrscht noch
unsicherheit in den impfzentren oder
adressen
ich würde nicht sagen uns sicherheit
sondern es geht im moment die regeln die
ebenen rein formal stichwort offizielle
beschluss facher saarmund
veröffentlichung eben zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt dann auch anzuwenden sind
sagt professor christian bock dann von
der ständigen impfkommission vielen dank
bis hierhin für ihr die beantwortung der
fragen und auch vielen dank an die
userinnen und user für die vielen fragen
wir werden versuchen das was noch dazu
rein kommt auch über das community
management zu beantworten während die
einen also verunsichert sind wegen der
impfungen auch wenn herr professor
bogdan das wort verunsicherung nicht
besonders mochte aber sie ist in großen
teilen der bevölkerung ja nun mal da
waren andere davor jetzt wegen delta
panik zu machen kassen arzt chef andreas
gassen kritisiert heute zitat es ist
unverantwortlich immer wieder mit
endzeit szenarien zu operieren aber ist
dass panik wenn man versucht sich
vorausschauend gedanken darüber zu
machen wie wir die pandemie im sommer
und dann auch im bevorstehenden herbst
bewältigen können
jonas post fasst die lage zusammen
blickt man auf die aktuelle coroner lage
in deutschland kann man sich eigentlich
freuen
die bundesweite inzidenz liegt bei 5,2
kein einziger kreis im land hat eine
inzidenz von mehr als 50 und mehr als
die hälfte der deutschen hat bereits
ihre erste impfdosis erhalten
doch die bislang dominierende alpha
variante des virus wird in deutschland
zunehmend durch die delta variante
verdrängt in der kalenderwoche 24 lag
ihr anteil an den crooner neuinfektionen
bei 36,7 prozent
noch ist unklar ob die delta variante
gefährlicher ist allerdings ist sicher
sie ist deutlich ansteckender müssen wir
uns jetzt sorgen machen
tja die frage gebe ich direkt weiter an
den virologen klaus stöhr herr stöhr
müssen wir uns sorgen machen
die sorgen sind immer gut das ist
richtig sie haben angefragt ob es jetzt
vernünftig wäre sich gedanken zu machen
wer das jetzt noch mal kommt und in den
herbst ein natürlich ist richtig aber
muss sich an die zahlen einmal halt man
warum sind die leute verunsichert weil
es immer wieder leute gibt die
tatsächlich entweder dinge erfinden oder
auch statements machen die irgendwie
scheinen beiden das narrativ hinein
passen wir haben ja gesehen dass vor 24
wochen immer noch einige gesagt haben ja
die täter variante die betrifft
natürlich viel mehr kinder kindergeld
mehr hospitalisiert und dann
gleichzeitig eingemachte jetzt muss man
natürlich die stiko und musste dort
kriegen damit die endlich die kinder
impfen und im herbst müssen wir auch
unbedingt die de schulen vorbereiten das
natürlich nur geimpfte kinder die in die
schule kommen was damit dass die zahlen
natürlich zeigen dass die dritte
variante in höheren anteil hat aber
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich um einige
die dann schon in die panik geraten dann
bleiben wir doch mal konkret also zum
einen die impfkommission hat ja nun
keine empfehlung ausgesprochen die
kinder impfen zu lassen das ist der
stand aktuell das müssen wir festhalten
und sie haben das stichwort
hospitalisierung angesprochen darauf
würde ich gerne eingehen
das rk ii selbst sagt dass durch delta
mehr menschen hospitalisiert werden
müssen gerade in einer jungen
altersgruppe also die zahlen des rk ii
besagen dass im alter zwischen 15 und 34
11 prozent hospitalisiert werden mit der
delta variante bei alfa sind es nur fünf
prozent
was sagen sie zu diesen zahlen anschauen
die kollegen haben natürlich längere
erfahrung schon aber das ist ganz also
ganz kurz bevor wir nach england schauen
dann schauen wir nach deutschland das
sind die zahlen vom rk ii das macht
ihnen keine sorgen
naja es ist ja so die del tabelle hat in
deutschland einen anteil je nach
bundesland zwischen 15 und 35
aber ich muss man auch sehen inwieweit
tatsächlich diese hospitalisierung die
kriegen ja immer so nach 10 15 tagen ein
dann auch tatsächlich das endresultat
dieser dabei hat man bei der alpha
variante auch schon gesehen da gab es
diese dritte welle und leute die gesagt
haben wir das land alpha variante hatten
keine zahlen gehabt das zu belegen die
konnten nicht sagen ob die zunahme diese
zweite welle im winter durch die alpha
tiere verursacht wurde durch benni
würdigkeit durch mehr testen oder durch
irgendetwas anderes für ihre mobilität
die wir gesehen haben
also müssen dann schon auch die ursachen
tatsächlich sehen warum sich solche
trends dann entwickeln
und da kann man nicht einfach sagen eine
beobachtung ist gleichzeitig kausalität
das ist nicht einfach nicht
verantwortlich für wissenschaften sie
haben selbst den blick nach england
angesprochen dann teilen wir auf die
zahlen wie sich delta dort entwickelt da
sind die neuinfektionen zuletzt rasch
angestiegen knapp 28.000 neuinfektionen
in den letzten 24 stunden
das bedeutet laut regierung dass die
zahl der ansteckungsfälle zwischen 25
juni und erster juli um fast 72 prozent
gestiegen ist wenn wir davon ausgehen
dass wir ein bisschen hinten dran gehen
eher hinten dran sind was das verhältnis
zwischen deutschland und england angeht
sehen sie nicht dass das was in england
passiert auch bald in deutschland
passieren könnte ja das kann passieren
die dabei wird hier auch zu nehmen die
englischen kollegen haben wir auch
natürlich andere zahlen müssen denn die
betrachtung gestellten in deutschland
liegen ungefähr 600 menschen noch
intensivstationen die meisten von denen
noch aus der dritten welle die täglichen
neuzugänge sind fast vernachlässigbar in
england liegen ungefähr 250 personen
werden dort liegen intensivstation
werden dort beatmet das ist also
anteilmäßig viel weniger als in
deutschland 60 millionen england 82
ungefähr in deutschland wenn die delta
bayern sind jetzt an englands ionen
hohen anteil an hat und mitte mai schon
50 prozent anteil hatte tatsächlich zu
stärkeren verkäufen führen würde dann
müssten sie auch mehr leute
prozentual auf die intensivstation die
insgesamt haben aber das ist es richtig
die hospitalisierung zugenommen also
muss das alles ein bisschen perspektiven
und vor allen dingen auch das was die
englischen kollegen sagen zu den kindern
nämlich dass kinder nicht
überproportional betroffen sind durch
die delta waren sich auch die
hospitalisierung wenn kinder nicht
überproportional zugenommen was hinter
dieser variante also es ist immer kein
vollständiges bild es ist schwierig zu
überblicken aber die statements
das unzweifelhaft die daten zeigen dass
das und das passiert und dass es
unstrittig ist dass dieses und jenes
dieser einfachen meinungen von
bestimmten politikern sind meines
erachtens und fragen deutlich man muss
das schon in die perspektive setzen
und deswegen ist es richtig zu sagen
jawohl ich älter werden müssen wir
beobachten vielleicht hat sie
tatsächlich ist der immunschutz bei den
impfungen leicht reduziert die
funktionieren aber immer noch dass alle
sehr gut aber deswegen brauchen der
zweiten halbzeit hatte außerirdisch gut
erklärt aber jetzt panikmache zu führen
es erinnert mich ein bisschen an die
alpha wo man gesagt hat ja turbo virus
neue pandemie was passt einfach glaube
ich nicht in das narrativ jetzt
gegenwärtig die zahlen denn alle im
sinkflug
wir haben den intent liegt um 5 607 alle
unterziehen gesamtdeutschland die
sterberate war noch nie so gering und
wenn man sich auch mal die sterberate in
england angeschaut weil die ganz ganz
kurz ich bin ganz prächtig ich gebe
ihnen ganz günstige gelegenheit zum luft
holen weil sie sagen die alpha variante
es vergleichbar behandelt worden
damals hat man panik gemacht und am ende
hat man festgestellt dass wäre gar nicht
nötig gewesen zumindest interpretiert
das so was sie gerade gesagt haben wir
haben gleichzeitig mit dem auftreten der
alpha variante in deutschland erlebt
dass leute geimpft wurden dass gerade
die älteren die besonders gefährdet
waren quasi rausgefallen sind aus dieser
gefährdungs gruppe weil sie ab januar
geimpft wurden und wir haben ja auch
noch weiter massnahmen gehabt wie zum
beispiel die bundes notbremse das kann
man ja bei der gesamtschau nicht außer
acht lassen oder noch keinen fall
das passt ja alles viel zu lange wenn
man sich anschaut dann die bundes wird
bremse eingetreten ist und wie man sich
die zahlen entwickelt haben und hat im
gesamten europa dann auch die zahlen
zurückgegangen sind wegen der deutschen
wird brennen sie dann hat man eben
gesehen dass diese saisonalität schon
eine sehr große rolle spielt und die
haben ja sehr viele leute vorher absolut
abgelehnt was macht maximal 20 prozent
aus also ist es schon richtig was man
besorgt das ist gar keine back ends weil
wir sind auch sehr viele menschen
gestorben und dann möchte ich auf keinen
fall wieder so eine winterwelt kommen
aber umsatz richtig vorzubereiten muss
man jetzt zum beispiel studien beginnen
und zu sehen wie die antikörper bei dem
erwähnt haben den anfang des jahres
geworden wie die verschwinden welche
altersgruppen sind ist in england hat
dieses joint committee for vaccination
und im himmel reichen schon gestern den
empfehlung gegeben hat sie sagte nur 70
jährigen sollen dann noch ein poster
bekommen alle die immungeschwächte und
bewusster bekommen und noch eine andere
gruppen die wollen haben und macht man
explizit gesagt die kinder und jüngere
altersgruppen wird man aus nehmen damit
man noch mal schauen wie sich das
entwickelt gibt es in deutschland schon
daten dazu wir sehen muss man also
impfen sollten dabei
da muss man die zahlen und fakten
angucken und wirklich nicht immer gleich
in das panik trompeten horn planen denn
nicht vergessen es wird noch nicht eine
zweite variante geben es wird noch eine
nette variante geben und vielleicht sind
die ja da ist der herbst eine letzte
frage von einem user namens kam 0 r über
youtube wie wird die lage im september
und oktober und damit verbinden möchte
ich noch eine frage von mir das was sie
als panikmache bezeichnet ist das nicht
einfach vorausschauend überlegen wir
sehen dass es im herbst vielleicht
wieder steigen könnte also müssen wir
jetzt sinnvolle maßnahmen treffen in den
schulen oder woanders also wo ist die
grenze zwischen panikmache und dinge die
einfach getan werden müssen damit und
damit bin ich jetzt bei der frage die
lage im september und oktober nicht aus
dem ruder läuft
ja das ist richtig das ist sicherlich
eine dünne linie aber schauen sie mal in
deutschland gibt es ganz tolle fach
gehört
theologie immunologie deutsche
gesellschaft pathetische infektologe
krankenhaushygiene ganz toll dass
öffentliches gesundheitswesen das ist
alles hoch kompetente politiker
wissenschaftler die ausgezeichnete
stellungnahme abgeben aber die haben
eigentlich relativ wenig es geschafft in
das in die öffentliche diskussion und
das öffentliche blickfeld
da gibt es einige wieder politiker die
sich jetzt sind die dieses vakuum
irgendwie benutzen um sich dort zu
profilieren
also an ich mache entsteht für mich dann
wo man sich neben dem wissenschaftlichen
konsens bewegt ziemliches stieg um
wissenschaftliche kenntnisse
strukturierte risikoeinschätzung erfolg
von kollegen die das breite die breite
des multidisziplinären des wissens
abbilden und dann ihre meinung äußern
ist kann keiner einzelnen so sein diesen
konsens zerstört ganz kurz ich möchte
ein bisschen zum ende noch mal weg vom
politiker bashing hin zu den sorgen und
nöten der leute denn ich sehe das ist
das was auch die leute umtreibt die uns
hier schreiben also noch mal die frage
an sie als virologen was erwarten sie
passiert im september und oktober also
es wird eine atmung erkrankung ist
winter wäre gehen
die wird sich in diesem jahr
unterscheiden zweifach von dem was wir
im letzten jahr gesehen haben erstens
wird werden die sterbefälle die schweren
erkrankungen die intensivstation
belegung werden anders sein als im
letzten jahr viel weniger weil
hoffentlich sehr viele menschen über 50
die haben hinten lassen dann könnte man
99 prozent der todesfälle im prinzip
vermeiden noch zu schweren erkrankungen
aber es wird natürlich noch sehr viele
junge leute geben die nicht noch nicht
haben impfen lassen desto später die
erste infektion mit dem pandemischen
virus ist und beim leben desto
schwieriger wird die erkrankung bis
zwölf jahren wird es wahrscheinlich sehr
wenig passieren seit über 20 jahren
sollten dies überlegen es kann noch
ausbrüche gegeben über 20 30 millionen
werden deutsche sogar noch keine
immunität haben also es kann auch viele
ausbrüche geben aber hauptsächlich im
milde infektionen vorausgesetzt dass ich
sehr viele menschen sagt der virologe
klaus stöhr vielen dank dass sie bei uns
in der sendung waren vielen dank fürs
mitmachen
und damit gehen wir von einem der sagt
es ist überhaupt keinen grund für panik
gegenüber zu einem der sagt
delta variante ist sie bislang
gefährlichste und wir müssen höllisch
aufpassen dass wir da nicht in die
nächste welle hineinlaufen nämlich den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
hallo herr lauterbach schön dass sie bei
uns in der sendung sind unter lauterbach
wenn es jemanden gibt der sich mit
politiker bashing auskennt dann sind sie
dass sie haben auch die diskussionen
verfolgt darüber wie gewarnt davor wird
das panik geschürt würde vor der delta
variante oder vor dem was man dagegen
tun müsste teilen sie das oder sind sie
eine von denen der sagt wir haben grund
zur panik jan krank und so van dyck und
ich wehre mich gegen diese willige
argumentation dass eine berechtigte
warnung vor einer neuen variante dass
das automatisch panikmache wäre
wir haben also bei der alpha variante
haben wir relativ schnell reagiert weil
wir die gefahr erkannt haben und haben
viele tausende leute retten können
das wäre sicherlich nicht gelungen wenn
wir länger gewartet hätten oder essen
hin und her philosophierte wert nicht
konsequent gerade wir haben in
deutschland sehr konsequent gehandelt in
der ersten welt und auch in der dritten
werde in der zweiten welle nicht ganz so
weil wir dort zu lange gezögert haben
aber wir sind insgesamt mit einer
sterblichkeit von 4 prozent deutlich
besser durch die panne wie bisher
gekommen
als fast alle anderen europäischen
länder
und das wäre sicherlich nicht gelungen
wären wir also die dinge auf die leichte
schulter genommen hätten oder hätten zu
lange gezögert oder hätten hin und her
diskutiert so ein beherztes reagieren
wir sind deutschland gezeigt haben hat
uns geholfen und das wird auch
international anerkannt und
international mehr als im inland jetzt
zu den feiern wurde der beweis ist es
auch so wir haben jetzt zwei
möglichkeiten wir können abwarten war
schon auch so was da passiert und mal
gucken ob das in deutschland sich auch
so fällt wie in england und der gleiche
oder wir anderen konsequent wir können
auch aus seinem langen diskurs darüber
führen also wie gefährliche data
variante ist aus meiner sicht wichtig
genug das ist 40 bis 60 prozent mehr an
stärke
auch darüber hinaus etwas resistenter
gegen die impfstoffe das haben wir
müssen reagieren da braucht man nicht
auch so in panik zu verfallen aber wir
mussten überlegen was wir machen müssen
das tempo beschleunigt und die stiko hat
heute die empfehlung gegeben
die astrazeneca dienten in der zweiten
impfung mit dem messenger und eigentlich
auch zu versorgen das ist richtig ich
bleibe bei der position kreis wie
unbeliebt ist ich weiß wie also haben
wir vorerst das ist habe ich glaube da
wäre noch gut bedient unsere kinder zu
impfen zwischen 12 und 16
ich erkenne auch dass die stiko eine
also unabhängige institution ist von
tracht wollten also sehr anerkannt sind
aber trotzdem dass es keine
majestätsbeleidigung wenn man
wissenschaftlich fundiert gegenposition
vorträgt und ich glaube dass wir also
sage ich mal sehr vorsichtig sagen
müssen die dawanda zu unterschätzen
wir werden also zunächst die situation
bekommen dass der alltag immer weiter
steigt und dann irgendwann im herbst
dann auch die zahl der infizierten
insgesamt steigen und darauf vorbereite
zahlen lauterbach gerade zum thema
kinder kommt hier eine frage von einem
user über youtube der lustigerweise
ernsthaft heißt der sich bei ihnen
übrigens zunächst für ihre arbeit
bedankt und dann aber fragt welche
massnahmen braucht es für die schulen
sind lehrkräfte auch im herbst geschützt
falls delta sich in den schulen
ausbreiten sollte ich glaube die
lehrkräfte werden zum allergrößten teil
also werden die games sein
wir haben den wesentlichen drei
möglichkeiten mit der schulung zu gehen
das ist was man sich das ein wichtiger
punkt da bin ich sehr dankbar für diese
fahrt ist halte ich die gefahr die erste
möglichkeit die wir haben das dass wir
also die kinder eben freiwillig
natürlich und somit also in der in den
schulen zu einer immunität kommen
irgendwo 50 60 prozent so dass der große
ausbrüche nicht erwarten müssen
die zweite möglichkeit ist wir machen
normal und unterricht und dann werden
wir das haben was wir jetzt auf mallorca
auf gesehen haben dann werden wir
riesige ausdrückt haben weil die data
variante wird ich bei normalen
schulunterricht ohne dass ich also
besondere vorkehrungen treffe werde sich
also schnell durchsetzen
und dort wird es große ausbrüche geben
dann geht
das immer wieder quarantäne begeben dann
müssen in quarantäne kommen zurück dann
sie dann also infiziert oder karten und
dergleichen also durchseuchung und
schulausfall oder aber wir machen wieder
das was wir letztes jahr gemacht haben
wir gehen in die kombination wechsel
unterricht und texten und das sind die
drei möglichkeiten es gibt es gibt keine
andere möglichkeit es gibt nicht die
folgen die möglichkeit dass man sagt wir
machen einigermaßen normalen unterricht
ohne wechsel unterricht und ohne festung
und trotzdem infizieren sich die kinder
nicht
diese möglichkeit wird mal der delta
bayern nicht erinnert sich an badeorte
somit sind dies die drei möglichkeiten
und wenn diese dauern möglichkeiten sind
finde ich es die impfung der kinder die
beste möglichkeit weiß irgendwann werden
wir den kindern nur zwei gruppen
diejenigen die firma kurve kappen oder
diejenigen die camp waren eine frage
kommt auch über youtube wiederum vom
user kann 0 r würden luftfilter in
schulen helfen die welle im herbst
abzumildern
ja sie würden helfen die welle
abzumildern aber die luft setzte die
jetzt zur verfügung stehen sind zu
wenige und das in großem stil wird
werden wir lernen doch fehlt da nicht
kaufen
ich habe das hier ausgeht kostet schon
im letzten jahr machen müssen dass es
sind zu wenige quantitativ weil zu
wenige auf dem markt sind oder es werden
damit so gar nicht in den schulen seien
und weil bis die kommunen diese ganzen
förder anträge ausgefüllt haben sind die
kinder schon aus der schule raus
genauso ist es die beste variante wird
schon zu einem großen teil und die
klassen befallen haben bevor wir also
kommunen hier entsprechenden anträge
gestellt haben und bewilligt haben das
thema viel früher machen müssen
wir haben was die luftfilter anleihen
anlagen angeht das also gleiche problem
wie beim letzten jahr erneut hoffen die
kommunen das ist gut geht ohne die
filteranlagen die kommunen hoffen darauf
dass die data variante nicht so schlimm
konto das nicht so viele kinder
infiziert sind und dass man mit ein
bisschen kartelle und seiner schule
auswahl über die runden geht
was würden sie
den eltern raten sollen die geld sammeln
und selbst luftfilter anlagen in die
klassenräume stellen
ich bin nicht geratet er jetzt dann also
ich kann nur soviel sagen ich habe meine
eigene tochter cindy hat im letzten jahr
sehr viel schülerzahl hinnehmen müssen
und ist zum glück was ist eine sehr gute
schülerin ist irgendwie klar gekommen
aber ich habe mit ihr selbst aber ich
brauche sie ganz sich mittlerweile
selbst sehr gut aus und also wir haben
uns für die ebenfalls gemeinsam
entschieden
dann blicken wir jetzt am ende der
sendung noch mal auf das thema reisen
denn die große frage ist ja was delta
uns in diesem sommer bescheren oder
bereiten wird
und wir schauen noch einmal auf die
zahlen wie sie gerade in europa aussehen
das vereinigte königreich ist mit großem
abstand das land in europa in dem sich
die delta variante schon am stärksten
verbreitet hat im durchschnitt der
letzten vier wochen waren hier 94
prozent der krone neuinfektionen auf sie
zurückzuführen
ebenfalls in portugal dominiert die
delta variante schon auch an anderen
beliebten urlaubsländern wie kroatien
spanien und italien hat sich die
variante schon stärker ausgebreitet
im vergleich dazu sind die werte in
deutschland noch geringer
doch auch hier steigen sie stark an
herr lauterbach wofür steht das für mehr
grenzkontrollen oder vielmehr urlaub in
deutschland also mehr urlaub in
deutschland ist immer eine gute idee
aber ich glaube dass noch so in ganz
europa sich die data variante durchsetzt
daher also bin ich der meinung dass wir
für diejenigen die nicht geimpft sind
im test verlangen müssen und zwar 24
einen test bei der anreise und nach fünf
tagen wo ich glauben wo wir abstand
nehmen sollten jetzt das folgende wir
haben jetzt diese regelung diejenigen
die aussagen im biosphärengebiet kommen
zum beispiel aus england und aus fotos
und es werden ja noch mehr dieser
gebiete jetzt kommen sie müssen in 14
tagen
taylor selbst dann wenn sie ab wenn sie
vollständig also zu haben ergeben sind
von dieser regelung würde ich abstand
nehmen denn diejenigen die also gegen
die gewinns von sind beginnen frauen
sind die sind in der regel die der feier
ausreichend geschützt so dass eine 14
tägige quarantäne für diejenigen die
eben waren vollständig irgendwann und
die aus einem varianten gebiet kommen wo
die delta warnten vor davor steht nicht
nötig ist dann die abschlussfrage an sie
herr lauterbach wird uns delta den
sommer vermiesen sondern nicht meine
sorge ist ehrlich gesagt dass es im
herbst problem ergeben wird und ich
mache mir die meisten sorgen noch bei um
die schulen und um die kinder
weil ich davon ausgehe dass wir da in
ich werde ich gut vorbereitet zahlen
werden und dass die kinder die also um
gm sind das die größten probleme haben
werden sagte spd gesundheitsexperte karl
lauterbach vielen dank dass sie bei uns
in der sendung waren und auch an sie
liebe userinnen und user herzlichen dank
fürs mitmachen und ich hoffe sie haben
trotz allem einen schönen sommer und bin
mir sicher wir werden über das thema
corona hier an dieser stelle in all
seinen facetten noch viel und oft
miteinander sprechen dankeschön fürs
mitmachen bis zum nächsten mal